sénateur du jour il est élu devant des
sièges dans le groupe l'est républicain
et donc le rapporteur de cette loi
mobilité qui est examiné au sénat cet
aprem dit bonjour 10e an des jo merci
d'être avec nous ce matin on va parler
bien sûr de la loi mobilité mais à lens
à quelques questions d'actualité le
gouvernement qui fera des annonces de
main sur l'immigration à l'issue d'un
comité interministériel et selon les
premières informations et bien il
envisage d'organiser dès l'année
prochaine un débat annuel au parlement
pour définir des quotas
par secteur d'activité est ce que c'est
une idée que vous soutenez je pense
qu'on ne peut être que favorable à toute
mesure qui vise à fluidifier à organiser
l'arrivée chez nous deux de milliers de
dizaines de milliers de personnes et
c'est bien que le gouvernement s'empare
de ces sujets sans parle de cette
question de l'immigration je serais
tenté de dire il est temps puisque
depuis quelques années c'est un sujet
qui taraude les français avec d'autres
sujets bien évidemment et je pense qu'il
est nécessaire que que l'exécutif se
saisissent de de ce sujet qu'est ce que
vous attendez d'autres vous comme mesure
qu est ce qu il faut faire en priorité
je pense qu'un sermon de mesures à
prendre sur le territoire évidemment
mais ça ne peut être efficace que si
dans le même temps selon la formule
consacrée
nous avons un geste fort en matière de
développement il faut accompagner les
pays qui qui voit partir souvent les
plus jeunes de leurs ressortissants pour
chercher ailleurs pour fuir un centre de
conditions et pour chercher ailleurs
ceux qui sont légitimement ou en attente
c'est à dire une vie meilleure et un
épanouissement dans leur quotidien on va
parler d'un autre sujet d'actualité
si vous connaissez bien ce sont ces
inondations la tempête a méné a frappé
la france ce week-end vous avez connu en
vendée la tempête xynthia est ce que
vous pensez que les leçons et est serrée
face à ce genre de catastrophe pas
complètement une certaine forme
d'accoutumance je peine à dire encore de
résilience à ces phénomènes qui à la
fois sont de plus en plus fréquent est
de plus en plus intense la mission qui
vient de donner son rapport pondu par
nicole bonnefoy et michel vaspart
d'ailleurs le
le traduit plus de 55 mesures dont
certaines qui vise à améliorer la
prévention n'a pas la culture du risque
en france
malgré ces conditions difficiles depuis
nombreuses années nous n'avons pas la
culture du risque et il faut absolument
que nos concitoyens que nous nos
collectivités puissent mener des actions
pour sensibiliser les gens qui vivent à
la fois bien sûr sur le littoral est au
bord des rivières et des fleuves ou sont
densifiés les populations mais également
tous les autres acteurs et phénomènes
climatiques c'est bien sûr les
inondations les tempêtes mais c'est
aussi la sécheresse les phénomènes de
monsieur sur sur les habitations avec
l'argile qui se rétracte et c'est donc
il ya un grand du activités ne sont
toujours pas prête à affronter ce genre
de catastrophe
la puissance publique au sens large
parce qu'on n'a pas cette culture moi je
suis né dans la chance d'être dans des
pays où cette culture est très prégnant
puisque les pays sont très vulnérables
je pense à madagascar notamment où dès
leur plus jeune âge les enfants ont des
réflexes acquiert des reflex avec des
drapeaux de couleurs pour prévenir et
pour se protéger et puis se mettre à
l'abri donc je pense qu'on n'a pas cette
culture encore ancré chez nous comme
c'est le cas par exemple aux pays bas où
le risque est permanent
eh bien il nous appartient
collectivement de prendre les
dispositions pour y parvenir pour vous
c'est quoi les dispositions les plus
urgentes à prendre parce qu'on voit que
ce genre de phénomène est amené à se
multiplier
il ya à la fois la mise en oeuvre d'un
certain nombre de deux ouvrages de
protection
je pense au dic par exemple sur le
littoral et la vendée connaît
parfaitement ce phénomène mais également
sur d'autres secteurs des conséquences
en matière d'urbanisation par exemple et
un sérum d'aménagement qui sont
nécessaires qui serait nécessaire pour
pour faire face augmenter notre capacité
à faire face
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle la
résilience tout simplement allez on va
passer à cette loi mobilité dont vous
êtes le rapporteur elle est examinée cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
remet en parle avec notre journaliste
parlementaire dang tran huy j'entame
bonjour oriane cette matinale
aujourd'hui les sénateurs vont donc à
examiner ce projet de loi mobilité et
table ça ne devrait pas prendre beaucoup
de temps et oui tout simplement parce
que les sénateurs devraient refuser de
débattre du texte et ils vont adopter
une motion de procédure une question
préalable que vous allez présenter
didier mandelli c'est une arme qui
permet de stopper les débats et de dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec le texte
et pourtant au mois d'avril dernier lors
de l'examen en première lecture du même
projet de loi les relations eh bien elle
était au beau fixe
écoutez justement d'un elisabeth baume à
l'époque elle était encore ministre des
transports c'était le 2 avril dernier
écoutez moi je voudrais saluer
l'adoption par une très large majorité
du projet doit d'orientation des
mobilités le texte tel que vous venez de
l'adopter en première lecture respecte
les grands équilibres que j'ai défendu
et je ne peux que m'en réjouir
je me félicite notamment du consensus
qui existe sur l'un des principes
structurants de ce projet de loi à
savoir la couverture complète du
territoire par des autorités
organisatrices en charge de la mobilité
peut paraître être une mesure technique
mais je pense que c'est grâce à ça que
plus aucun français ne sera laissé
demain sans solution
on l'entend tams était la lune de miel
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
oui aïe aïe aïe à la machine s'est
grippée pour une histoire est bien une
histoire de gros sous
depuis le début les sénateurs ont peur
que les budgets ne soit pas à la hauteur
des mesures contenues dans le texte est
là avec le dévoilement du projet de loi
de finances 2009 1 et bien entendu tout
simplement la confirmation leur couru il
est lié à deux raisons principales
d'abord et bien la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation va dire encore et
toujours et ses conséquences pour
l'intercommunalité
et puis le deuxième problème c'est la
perte immédiate de 45 millions d'euros
pour les autorités organisatrices de la
mobilité c'est-à-dire les collectivités
en charge de l'organisation des
transports sur un territoire donné
c'est ironique parce que précisément
c'est sur ce point sur les autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité que la
ministre se félicitait au mois d'avril
dernier conte et du quota mme colle est
la conséquence de ces pertes de budgets
eh bien les sénateurs ne vois pas
comment ces autorités vont pouvoir
développer les alternatives à la voiture
individuelle et mettre fin aux zones
blanches de la mobilité c'est-à-dire
satisfaire les objectifs de la loi
l'homme
ce sont des sujets importants ces sujets
ce sont ceux des fractures territoriales
tout ça ça a été au coeur de la fronde
et 80 km heure est au coeur du
déclenchement du mouvement des gilet
jaune reste que ça veut dire pour autant
que les sénateurs sont contre ce texte
ah oui ça c'est tout le paradoxe c'est
tout le contraire parce que la deuxième
raison pour laquelle les sénateurs
veulent d'écourter les débats
c'est qu'ils ont obtenu gain de cause
sur quasiment tout ce qu'il voulait bref
tout le monde est d'accord sur le
diagnostic les solutions mais pas sur
les moyens
si les combats seront donc écourté sur
la loi l'homme ce n'est que pour mieux
reprendre son souffle
rendez vous donc pour l'examen du budget
et vous viendra nous raconter que ça
toute alerte à didier mandelli vous me
confirmer que cet après midi vous
refuserez débattre de ce texte
oui cela nous avons posé la question
préalable pour mettre fin à l'examen de
ce texte ici au sénat pour deux raisons
essentielles elles viennent d'être
évoqués
la première c'est que la quasi totalité
des éléments que nous avions intégré
dans le texte
à l'occasion de la première lecture
puisque nous avons démarré l'examen au
sénat sont maintenus dans le texte
non seulement ce que nous avons voté au
sénat mais ce qui avait été préparé en
vue de la commission mixte paritaire qui
a fait l'objet d'un échec donc pour
cette première raison nous n'avons pas
d'opportunités de nouveaux éléments a
rajouté le texte est quasi identique à
celui que nous avions voté
et puis je dirais que le deuxième point
qui est un point essentiel c'est le
financement c'est le seul point sur
lequel nous avons un chopper en
commission mixte paritaire puisque dès
le départ nous avions dit à isabelle
borne alors ministre des transports que
nous n'avions pas dans ce texte les
éléments de financement pour les
collectivités pour les intercommunalités
notamment et que nous avons intégrés
dans le texte un volet financement à la
fois avec une fraction des icpe et un
taux minoré à 0,3 je rentrais pas dans
le détail pour les intercoms qu'ils
saisiraient de cette compétence et c'est
avec le financement depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte avant même son
arrivée au parlement la question c'était
le financement vous dites que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait les efforts
nécessaires sur ce sujet non il n'y a
pas de financement la règle que nous
sommes fixés au sénat c'est pas de
compétences nouvelles obligatoire ou
transférées aux collectivités locales
sans les financements correspondance
c'est une règle immuable
aujourd'hui 80% des intercoms enfin des
territoires ne sont pas couverts par une
autorité organisatrice et pires dans le
projet de loi de finances nous
découvrons que les les autorités
organisatrices qui donc mettez en oeuvre
du transport régulier notamment puisque
c'était l'obligation se voit grévé de 45
millions d'euros qui était en réalité
une compensation de l'état depuis 2016 à
une mesure de relèvement des seuils de
celle qui prendrait la compétence qui ne
l'ont pas encore aujourd'hui n'auront
pas de financement à ce jour et celles
qui la mettait en oeuvre cette
compétence se voit grévé de 45 millions
d'euros avec les impacts de la loi pacte
que nous avons votée au printemps
dernier et bien c'est entre entre 20 et
55 millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
ne seront pas perçues par les
collectivités puisque le versement
transport
il est lié à des effets de seuil
également au niveau de la masse
salariale et du nombre des employés donc
ces deux effets conjugués font que les
collectivités locales qui exerce
aujourd'hui la compétence vont se voir
vont voir leur budget diminue de 100
millions d'euros dans les années qui
viennent donc c'est pas possible
ce texte il avait aussi pour but à la
base de tenter de résorber les fractures
territoriales est ce que vous dites que
l'objectif ait raté non parce que il
restera à voir de quelle façon les
intercomités vont se saisir ou pas de la
compétence elles ont en quelques mois
pour le décider si l'autorité locale si
l'intercommunalité ne se soucie pas de
la compétence et la région qui de fait
mécaniquement aura cette compétence la
compétence sera assumée soit par
l'interco soit par la région de fait
donc les régions devront on commençait
pour certaines à se saisir de ce sujet à
faire des propositions à leurs
collectivités de leur territoire pour
répondre tenté de répondre après sur
dans les très grandes régions quand il
faudra faire d'eux des actions ou des
mesures très fine sur le territoire sera
peut-être plus compliqué il faudra
déployer sans doute un terme de moyens
complémentaires
c'est un ses factures territoriale
justement elle était à l'origine elle
était une des causes de cette crise des
gilet jaune il ya maintenant un an
quasiment jour pour jour
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement à tirer les leçons de cette
crise pas pas complètement je pense mais
dans notre pays qui est un pays endetté
qui a déficit chronique on a du mal à
investir et l'objectif de bercy comme on
dit souvent c'est de faire des économies
par tous les moyens ont donc évoqué tout
à l'heure la question de la prévention
sur les risques naturels majeurs le fond
et est ponctionnée régulièrement tous
les ans c'est vrai sur un ensemble de
moyens donc on n'a pas la capacité à
investir et à prendre en compte et les
réels besoins de nos populations que ce
soit dans le domaine de la santé que ce
soit dans le domaine des infrastructures
je rappelle simplement que dans le cadre
des mobilités conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures avait défini un certain
nombre de pistes et dax et nous sommes
au scénario moyen donc se dire que pour
doter le pays des infrastructures et
permettent la mobilité de chacun de nos
concitoyens il faudrait qu'on puisse
investir c'est pas énorme à l'échelle du
pays c'est un milliard et demi d'euros
supplémentaires chaque année on n'est
pas capable de les trouver
on va parler d'un autre sujet que vous
connaissez bien et dont vous occupe au
sénat c'est la snsm ce sont les
sauveteurs en mer vous êtes le
rapporteur d'une
si on d'information sénatoriale qui a
été créée après le décès de trois
sauveteurs en juin dernier vous avez
rendu vos conclusions il ya quelques
jours on va en parler mais d'abord on va
regarder puisque jérôme rabier notre
journaliste vous avez suivi sur le
terrain lors de vos travaux
c'était à ouistreham on va écouter
quelques témoignages forts il a fallu
attendre une grande une grande
catastrophe pour que digne et une prise
de conscience à la hauteur de l'état et
moi je ne cache pas que j'attends
beaucoup beaucoup de cette mission
j'attends beaucoup de vous et il était
temps il était temps que qu'on
reconnaisse cette action bénévole on
veut pas dire que c'était des vols
doivent être payés ces bénévoles voilà
déjà la première chose d'être reconnus
reconnut-il états devaient assurer ce
sauvetage partout il faudrait qu'il
mette un service de garde côtes en place
c'est à dire qu'avec des gens payés 24
heures sur 24 à attendre le sauvetage ce
serait un coût prohibitif
alors que la salle ça ne coûte rien à
l'état bénévolement tous les gens sont
bénévoles
donc je dirais que les première chose à
faire c'est déjà de l'argent pour
l'investissement
ça c'est la première chose qui nous
sommes très important dixième en délire
on entend ces témoignages est ce que
vous diriez qu'il y aura un avant et un
après 7 juin c'est le jour de cette
catastrophe du décès de ces trois
sauveteurs en mer oui j'espère en tout
cas sinon ce sera désespérer de tout
nous avons dans ce rapport qui est basé
d'ailleurs sur l'essentiel des
témoignages des sauveteurs que nous
avons rencontrés à l'occasion depuis une
douzaine de visites sur le terrain nous
avons rencontré des dizaines de stations
des centaines de bénévoles qui nous ont
exprimé ce que ce que vient ce que
viennent d'exprimer les deux sauveteurs
que nous avons entendu c'est à la fois
un besoin énorme de reconnaissance des
missions qui sont dévolues aux
sauveteurs de façon bénévole
et puis un problème de financement et
nous y avons rajouté un puisque s'était
mis à jour un problème de gouvernance
également au niveau de la snsm sur sur
le on apparaître ce financement mais on
a l'impression que ce que veulent avant
tout les sauveteurs c'est de la
reconnaissance plus que des moyens
il ya un problème de reconnaissance
aujourd'hui oui parce que ce sont des
gens qui se dévouent
corps et âme qui paie quelquefois un
lourd tribut on l'a vu aux sables
d'olonne leur mission est en réalité ils
ont le sentiment que à la fois l'état
c'est moins vrai pour les collectivités
locales qui sont souvent à leurs côtés
physiquement n'ont pas cette
reconnaissance à la fois deux voies la
de de l'électro salle oui alors je
dirais que c'est à la fois l'état mais
également le siège de la snsm qui paraît
trop éloignés de nos stations
ça fait partie des questions de
gouvernance que nous avons traité pour
lesquels nous avons fait une dizaine de
propositions dans son rapport sur les 30
que contient le rapport
est ce que vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui le
système français de sauvetage en mer qui
est basée sur le bénévolat est menacée
il n'est pas menacé il est exemplaire il
est assez extraordinaire il faut le
préserver dans cette forme mais en
aménageant à la fois sur les questions
de financement en dégageant les
bénévoles et les stations locales de la
recherche de financement et non pas
besoin ils ont tous exprimé de passer
leur temps à faire la quête entre
guillemets à vendre des calendriers
faire des galettes saucisses sont aussi
leur expression pour trouver quelques
euros ici et là pour financer leur
propre bateau on leur demande de
financer leur bateau c'est comme si on
demandait à un sapeur pompier volontaire
de financer son camion ou un pilote de
canadair de financer son avion donc on
en est là sur le sur le sauvetage en mer
donc il faut les dégager de cette charge
lourde qui pèse sur leurs épaules et il
leur laisser du temps pour consacrer
bien sûr à leur formation
et ça fait partie aussi de la
reconnaissance quand un sauveteur fait
une formation au pôle national à saint
nazaire il prend une semaine ou deux par
an sur son temps de travail sur son
temps de famille de façon bénévole donc
il faut aussi reconnaître ces formations
travers de la validation des acquis y
compris dans l'entreprise avec des
conventions avec les entreprises par
exemple employeuse voilà donc on a fait
l'un encore une dizaine de propositions
sur ces sujets qui devrait permettre de
faciliter l'exercice des missions alors
le gouvernement a annoncé 4 5 millions
d'euros 1 pour la snsm se sera inscrit
dans le budget 2020 est ce que vous
dites c'est déjà ça c'est déjà un
premier pas oui c'est une avancée en
réalité le ce que donnait l'état ya
quelques années c'était 2 millions
d'euros par an sur un coût estimé
d'une centaine de millions pour le
sauvetage en mer snsm assurant 50% de ce
sauvetage
le coût que représente la part bénévoles
c'est de l'ordre de 44 millions d'euros
ce que donne en fait les bénévoles à la
csa mais à l'état et donc on est passé
de 2 à 6 millions d'euros et on passe à
dix millions et demi aujourd'hui donc
c'est un pas essentiel
moi ce que je souhaite et je les dix
mêmes bornes la ministre la semaine
dernière quand je lui ai remis avec
corinne féret la présente le rapport
c'est que c'est ces millions d'euros
soit fléchés vers l'investissement
il faut absolument que dans les dix ans
qui viennent nous réussissions pour le
moment ce n'est pas garanti que vous
non parce que ils sont affectés à la
snsm ces fonds mais il faut je dirais
pas contraindre mais avec la snsm bâtir
un programme pluriannuel
d'investissement prévisionnel avec les
collectivités locales qui contribuent
largement aussi à près de 50% au
financement des bateaux eh bien il faut
planifier sur les dix ans qui viennent
le renouvellement de 140 bateaux c'est
plus de 100 millions d'euros
et bien cette part consacrée à l'état
doit être en grande partie réservée au
financement des bateaux pour soulager
les bénévoles des stations de saint
elisabeth berne est prête à le faire on
a entendu le message en tout cas et nous
avons une table ronde cette semaine
jeudi et je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion puisque moi j'interviens sur
la question du financement de refaire
passer ce message avec je l'espère une
écoute attentive de la ministre et de du
siège de la ceni en suivra ça comme tous
les gens disaient mandela on va se
rendre dans une rédaction locale
aujourd'hui direction
alci retrouver nos partenaires du
dauphiné bonjour julien ray strange ans
vous êtes le directeur des éditions
savoie et haute savoie du dauphiné ce
matin vous allez nous parler du
doublement des voies sncf entre annecy
et aix les bains exactement et c'est une
vieille histoire puisque cette ligne
date de 1880 depuis cette époque où
presque dix ans par deux sont doublement
puisqu'ainsi reste une ville qui est
relativement mal desservies par le rail
il ya même des associations d'usagers
qui milite pour ce projet lors de sa
dernière grande version date est bien de
la candidature d'annecy aux jeux
olympiques de 2018 bon annecy n'a pas eu
les n'a pas eu les jeux mais le projet
est resté et c'est celui-ci qui revient
aujourd'hui sur le
le devant de la scène puisque une
enquête publique s'est ouverte le 4
novembre elle va se poursuivre jusqu'au
4 décembre pour tenter de lancer ce
projet de doublement de cette de cette
voie sncf ont surchargé aujourd'hui
justement vous dit qu'elle est surchargé
est ce que vous pouvez nous faire en
point sur l'état de cette ligne
aujourd'hui
oui et tout à fait c'est une quelconque
de 40 km entre les deux entre les deux
villes annecy haute-savoie et
aix-les-bains en savoie
la partie qui sera qui sera à double
m.le mesure que que 15 km parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de problèmes techniques
notamment travers des gorges qui sont
assez profonds des gorges du fier il ya
dix neuf passages à niveau il n'ya pas
loin de tremper est aujourd'hui déjà
eh bien il ya sept mille 700 voyageurs
quotidiens qui prennent qui entraîne ces
lignes à des tgv et des ter qui
circulent et décide du mail 30 et j'en
attends une augmentation de 20% du
trafic c'est-à-dire aux alentours de 9
mille trois cents passagers et qu'ils
seront amenés à prendre cette ligne
toujours donc c'est dire s'il faut là il
faut la moderniser faudra moderniser les
voies les doubler il faudra aussi
moderniser signal et il faudra
moderniser un certain nombre
d'équipements il ya tout ça devrait
coûter pas loin de 310 millions d'euros
il y en a déjà 160 qui sont inscrits au
contrat de plan état région pour
financer donc cesser de dire s'il aussi
le projet est un projet important pour
les deux départements de la savoie et de
la haute-savoie pour les liaisons entre
les entre ces deux villes d un peu plus
largement générer ce range à le trans
est un moyen de désenclaver les ailes
parce qu'il ya d'autres projets en cours
bien sûr bien sûr alors sans vous parler
tout de suite du fameux du famille lyon
turin qui est un projet à très long
terme et qui concernera plutôt le plus
tôt le fret
il ya un autre projet qui est bien plus
abouti c'est le projet de ces var on dit
aujourd'hui plutôt léman express et bien
c'est un on va dire un rer
transfrontalier d'ailleurs ce sera le
premier transfrontalier d'europe qui
doit relier la france à la suisse dans
le bassin genevois on est vraiment dans
une configuration là pour le très très
urbaine et lui il est bien plus avancé
puisque sa mise en service est bien est
prévue dès le 15 décembre prochain
on a investi pas loin d'un milliard et
demi de francs suisses côté suisse et
aux alentours de 230 240 millions
d'euros côté français dans ce projet n'a
donc qui lui est aboutie et démarrera
dès le 15 décembre prochain
merci beaucoup julien on va regarder
ensemble à une
dauphiné libéré ce matin une seule les
agriculteurs un an après l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi et gally magli
culteurs le compte n'y est pas on en
parlera tout à l'heure plus longuement
dans le club des territoires merci
julien et strange un directeur des
éditions savoie et haute savoie au
dauphiné libéré d'avoir été en direct
avec nous ce matin viser new delhi on va
maintenant regarder la revue de presse
de votre département de la vendée c'est
avec tam qui revient et hamon va
commencer la revue tracés à quoi seront
effectivement ouest france qui consacre
sa une à la question du mal logement le
mal logement
un mal français met aussi à mal et bien
marseillais on est un an après
l'effondrement des deux immeubles de la
rue d'aubagne vous allez me dire didier
mandelli tout cela n'est pas très locale
rassurez-vous nous allons aussi dans les
pages intérieures avec un sujet qui
concerne lui la roche sur yon où la
maison médicale de garde veut se faire
connaître alors vous avez vu regardez il
y à un seul numéro le 116 117 un seul
lieu le centre hospitalier hospitalier
de la roche sur yon pour accueillir et
bien tous les patients avec des médecins
généralistes qui vous accueille et bien
après 20 heures le week-end mais aussi
les jours fériés et on passe à présent à
france bleu loire océan qui s'est mis
alors sinon instable effectivement
l'heure chinoise puisque emmanuel macron
est actuellement en train de faire son
voyage dans l' empire du milieu et la
région pays de la loire veut que les
entreprises exportent davantage vers
l'asie et la chine nous explique france
bleu mais vous allez voir c'est pas
gagné aucun patron de la région ne sera
du voyage présidentiel explique france
bleu on se quitte la délégation chinoise
est très complexe et elle évolue en
permanence et en gros l'article explique
aux deux tiers incombe d'indiens les
voix de l' empire du milieu et bien sont
impénétrables pour les français et
notamment pour la région pays de la
loire tout de même rassurez-vous les
pays de la loire ont identifié deux
secteurs à fort potentiel
le vin et la viande bovine ou fin vous
nous rassurer on va terminer avec le
reporter sable est oui le reporter
sablais qui se pose la question les
exploitations agricoles de vendée sont
elles en règle vous tremblez
dié demandé il ya des contrôles dans ses
exploitations qui concerne la santé des
animaux leurs conditions de vie
protection de l'environnement
utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques les pesticides
conditions d'attribution des aides de la
pac la politique agricole commune et
bien rassurez vous sur les 1700
exploitation environs qui ont été
contrôlés bien y en a seulement 75 76
qui ont des petites anomalies en gros 95
% des exploitations sont en règle bah
vous nous rassurer beaucoup ce matin
merci maman vont tourner tout à l'heure
des aimants des lions puisqu'on parlait
agriculture le sénat fait aujourd'hui le
bilan de la loi et galim ça fait un an
qu'elle est entrée en vigueur cette loi
qui disait à rééquilibrer les relations
entre les agriculteurs et les
distributeurs
est ce que cette loi est un échec
j'avais que c'est assumé échec à ce
stade il est encore un peu tôt pour
juger des effets puisque les
négociations l'an dernier ont eu lieu
après la promulgation de la loi
donc c'est un peu prématuré mais mais
globalement enfin c'est pas non plus une
surprise
ça fait longtemps ça fait quelques
décennies que les ministres successifs
la fois de la culture et d'économie
tente de trouver des solutions n'y sont
pas parvenus et moi j'avais le sentiment
en regardant et en regardant cette loi
de près quand elle était arrivée ici que
cela ne résoudrait pas la quasi-totalité
des problèmes auxquels sont confrontés à
nos agriculteurs
je dirais que c'est pas c'est patent
enfin on est moi je suis pour pour la
liberté et je pense que fixer les prix
c'est contraire à l'esprit du marché
même s'il faut préserver des
agriculteurs moi je pense qu'il aurait
été plus judicieux
d'exonérer de charge l'ensemble des
producteurs qui sont confrontés à des
concurrences bien sûr mondial sur
internet de produits
je pense qu'il faut aller ce que demande
des agriculteurs c'est pas qu'on
administre les prix et leurs activités
c'est qu'on leur aise la liberté qu'on
abaisse la recharge et qu'il puisse
affronter la concurrence et négociée au
travers de leur structure quelle qu'elle
soit coopérative d'ailleurs ou ou privé
avec les opérateurs qu'ils côtoient au
quotidien
il ya un système avec un un poids
certain de la grande distribution en
france des entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire qui transforme et qui
sont quelquefois exemple elle aussi
parce que les marges sont très réduites
parce qu'il ya une pression sur les prix
donc c'est l'ensemble de la filière qui
doit ré de la chaîne qui doit être
remise en question
merci beaucoup merci didier mandelli
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin on suivra
le bref examen on voit la loi mobilité
cet après midi au sénat dans deux
minutes c'est l'heure de l'invité
politique ce matin c'est valérie rabault
la présidente du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
on prendra entre autres des annonces à
venir sur l'immigration mais aussi des
privatisations celle de la fdj et celle
d'aéroports de paris mais d'abord un
extrait d'auditions publiques c'est
l'émission politique des chaînes
parlementaires hier soir francis
letellier recevait alexis corbière le
député la france mise de seine saint
denis il est revenu sur les incidents
qui ont eu lieu ce week-end à chanteloup
les vignes et la situation dans les
banlieues pour lui les conditions sont
réunies pour que ça explose à nouveau
regarder cet extrait
[Musique]